[Music]
see takes place about 600 years after a
viral apocalypse those who survived for
left blind and the world has gone back
to a tribal culture it's so very
different it's just something that has
never been done before we've been
working with to build this world what it
looked like what it would feel like
the world has been rebuilding itself
both in the natural environment that we
see here also the kind of people and how
they live together there is a beauty
about it mankind with nothing to
distract other than to keep life going
the idea is that the human beings who
did all the damage that the earth in the
first place can't see it then vision
comes back the ability to see characters
were blind or visually impaired haven't
often had an opportunity to portray
aspects outside of showing off their
disability
I trained actors how we move through the
world and help them understand how
people utilize their senses in a
different way prepared for a long
journey action-packed school stuff
that we've never seen before
[Music]
star home we are won by this point
you
[Music]